In the human population for the ABO gene,
at position 258, if you have a deletion
right there, then you actually have blood type
O. And the reason you have blood type O
is because you end up with a, a
deletion that causes a premature stop codon, because
we end up with this huge frame shift
in the letters. For the rest of the sequence.
Remember this happened very early right, in the coding region. We're
only at position 250 to 270. We go all the way
out to like a thousand in this gene. So at this
very early position, we've got a stop code on, so we're
going to end up with a much shorter protein overall. So take
a minute and think. What do you think is the result
of the protein's overall function. If you have a much shorter
version of the protein. Think about it for a second and
then put your answer in this text box here.